[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم يوم الخامس من يونيو اعلنت
ثلاث دول خليجيه حصارا على قطر وانضم
اخرون الى الركب باشكال مختلفه بعدها بشهر
يوم الاربعاء الخامس من يوليو اجتمع وزراء
خارجيه دول الحصار في القاهره وتمخض
اجتماعهم عن بيان استبقت البيان تكهنات
وتهديدات بمزيد من العقوبات والمقاطعه
والعزل فما الذي تمخض عنه هذا البيان لا
شيء يذكر سوى اتهامات مكرره لقطر فما الذي
حدث لا احد يعرف على وجه الدقه لكن اثناء
اجتماع الوزراء اعلن البيت الابيض ان
الرئيس الامريكي دونالد ترامب اجرى اتصالا
هاتفيا بالرئيس المصري عبد الفتاح السيسي
طلب فيه بحل الازمه الخليجيه بالتفاوض في
وقت كان فيه وزير الخارجيه القطري يدعو هو
ايضا للحوار من لندن نتابع هذا التقرير
لمريم اوبا
اييش اجتمعوا على قطر في القاهره خرج
وزراء خارجيه دول الحصار الثلاثي الخليجي
زائد مصر من اجتماعهم كما دخلوه بنفس
التصريحات السابقه والاتهامات للدوحه لم
يعلن او لا يعل بعد ما هو الاتي في الازمه
الخليجيه غير المسبوقه هل تغير بيان
الاجتماع في اللحظات الاخيره ظل لساعات
يعلن ان المؤتمر الصحفي المشترك سيعقد بعد
قليل في الحقيقه القليل كان ساعات سبق
المؤتمر الصحفي المشترك لوزراء خارجيه
الرباعي المحاصر لقطر بيان البيت الابيض
الامريكي جاء فيه ان الرئيس دونالد ترامب
اجرى اتصالا هاتفيا وهو وعلى متن طائرته
الخاصه بالرئيس المصري عبد الفتاح السيسي
وقال البيان ان ترامب دعا للتوصل الى حل
للازمه الدبلوماسيه مع قطر واضاف ان
الرئيس الامريكي اكد مجددا على حاجه كل
الدول لوقف تمويل
الارهاب الارهاب اكثر كلمه استخدمها وزراء
الخارجيه الاربعه في مؤتمرهم الصحفي
المعلومه الجديده الوحيده كانت الاعلان عن
اجتماع
الص البحرينيه المنامه اكثر سؤال طرح على
الوزراء كان ما هي الخطوات المقبله فعليا
لا احد كان لديه جواب واضح هناك
مقاطعه سياسيه مقاطعه اقتصاديه مقاطعه
فهذه هذه ستستمر الى ما حين تعدل قطر
سياساتها الى الافضل ونحن كلنا نامل ذلك
واكثر من استخدم نبره تصعيديه ضد قطر
المبتسم وغير الهادئ الوزير الاماراتي عبد
الله بن زايد ال
نهي لماذا لا تسعد قطر برسم الابتسامه على
اوجه
الناس ولكن مع الاسف قطر اثبتت لنا في
العقدين الماضيين ان
هوايتها
هو رسم الحزن في وجوه الناس
هو انتر الدم وهانتر الخراب الى ان قطر
تقرر تغيير هذا المسار من مسار الدمار الى
مسار
الاعمار
سنبقى في حاله انفصال عن قطر ربما لم
يتسنى للوزير الاماراتي متابعه المؤتمر
الصحفي لنظيره القطري في ختام جوله وزير
الخارجيه
للمنطقه عندما تقوم دوله قطر بتوفير
300000 وظيفه في منطقه شمال افريقيا فهي
تكافح الارهاب وتكافح الياس الذي يحيط
بالشباب عندما توفر التعليم ل 7 مليون طفل
في 42 دوله معناها انها
تستبدل السلاح بالقلم وتعلم وتسلح هؤلاء
الاطفال لعدم التعرض ل التنظيمات المتطرفه
ولا لا يجتذب لها معظم الاطفال في مخيمات
اللجوء يتلقون تعليمهم من مؤسسات تقوم
دوله قطر بدعمها وتبنيها
فمسهد لا تكون فقط بالسلاح وانما
بتسليح الشباب بالعمل وتمكينهم اقتصاديا
وتسليحهم تسليح الاطفال بالتعليم ويجب ان
توضع مساله الارهاب في سياقها الصحيح بان
الارهاب هو استخدام العنف ضد المدنيين
لتغيير الواقع وليس الارهاب هو اختلاف
الاراء
وتسميه المضادين السياسيين كارها بيين في
منبر اخر وهذه المره تشاتام هاوس في لندن
ذكر الشيخ محمد بن عبد الرحمن ال ثاني مره
اخرى ان بلاده منفتحه على الحوار وعلى اي
جهد جدي لحل الازمه الخليجيه مع ضروره
الحفاظ على السياده
القطريه انتهت المهل المعلنه ولم تنتهي
الازمه الخليجيه واذا كانت البدايه
المفاجئه لنشوب والقاسيه في اجراءاتها
الوصف للوزير السعدي الجبير هل ما بعدها
اقصى ام ان بيانات النهار ربما تختلف عن
تلك الصادره في
الظلم لمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا في
الاستديو الصحفي والاعلامي القطري احمد
سيطي ومن الكويت اسامه المناور عضو مجلس
الامه الكويتي السابق اهلا بضيفي الكريمين
معك السيد احمد سليطي هل خرج الاجتماع
بشيء يذكر نعم خرج
ببيان يحفظ وجه الدول المحاصره
ويضع الازمه ينقلها من الشخصنه الى الازمه
العامه وليست ازمه شخصيه لان ما ما قامت
عليه كانت امور شخصيه بحته لا تستقيم ولا
تتوافق مع السياسات الدوليه والعلاقات
الدوليه وجاءت الان في
متطلبات تتوافق مع القانون الدولي
والمتطلبات الدوليه وهذا ايضا ما اكده
الوزراء الاربعه اذا سمح لي الوقت ان انا
اعقب على البيان نفسه من الواضح هل البيان
هذا هل كان متوقعا هل هذا انت احمد سيطي
ما كنت تتوقعه فعلا من البيان بما جاء فيه
من نقاط وسردت فيه لا لم اكن اتوقع هذا
البيان ان ياتي بهذه الطريقه انا اتوقع
كنت اتوقع ان يكون هناك نوع من من العزه
بالاثم والمكابره والاستمرار على نفس
النهج لان في الحقيقه يعني الازمه بدات من
لا شيء وبدات لامور شخصيه وقرانا هذه
الامور الشخصيه في الخاصه بكل دوله على
حده من هذه الدول وقرانا هذه شخصنه الامور
في قائمه المطالب ال 13 ولكن عندما اجتمع
الدول الاربعه طبعا عكس ما يقول وزير
الخارجيه المصري ان هذا الاجتماع معد له
مسبقا في حين ان كانت التصريحات التي تسبق
هذا الاجتماع كانت تقول بان هذا الاجتماع
سيكون للرد
على تنسيق المواقف على المطالب على مط على
الردود
القطريه للوساطه الكويتيه
و ويخرج لنا وزير الخارجيه المصريه في
البيان يقول ان هذه من من تنسيق مسبق يعني
في الحقيقه اذا شفنا البيان كيف خرج نكتشف
ان الازمه كلها بدات بتغريده من ترامب
وانتهت بهذا المستوى باتصال هاتفي ايضا
بالنسبه لك الازمه انتهت لا لا لا انتهت
الى هذا المستوى اللي اللي عليه هي لم
تنتهي بعد لكن انتهت الى هذا المستوى الذي
انا اقرا فيه كثير من التناقض وكثير من
التراجع وال والنزول عن البرج العاجي الذي
كان يتكلم
فيه الدول الاربعه كان لافتا بالفعل هذا
الاتصال لترامب بدايه نود ان نعرف وجهه
نظرك لماذا اتصل باعتقادك لماذا اتصل وهو
على سفر من طائرته الرئاسيه وما الذي كان
في جعبته هل اتصل ربما لانه كان يعلم
بسيناريو معين توقع كثيرون من خلاله
التصعيد ام انه كان يعلم بان هذا ما سيخرج
به الاجتماع واتصل داعما لمواقف هذه شكرا
على لفت الانتباه بان الاتصال كان من
طائره اثناء موجوده في الطائره وهذا يدل
على ان اتصاله كان مهم
ل وصال الرساله لهذه الدول الاربعه
المجتمعه في القاهره بان يجب ان نتوقف هنا
يجب ان نفتح مجال ل للوساطه ويفتح مجال
للحل الازمه بطريقه دبلوماسيه بدلا من
التصعيد لان التصعيد سيجلب الى المنطقه
ككل قوى اخرى غير التي
تلعب في هذه الساحه اليوم غير ايضا
الرعايا الامريكيه للوساطه الكويتيه
وبالتالي كان الاتصال ضروري حتى لو كان
الرئيس الامريكي في طائره في طريقه الى
بولندا ف هذا الاتصال ما في شك ان هو يعني
وضع الامور عند هذا الحد مثل ما قلت انا
في بدايه الكلام هو بداها بدات الازمه
بتغريده الجماعه في هذه الدول الاربعه
بداوا افتعلوا الازمه معنا والان وصلوا
الى هذا المستوى المتدني نوعا ما من من
البدء في النزول انصح التعبير من المكان
البرج العاجل الذي كانوا هم فيه الى
الواقعيه في حتى هذه المبادئ السته التي
كتبوها
سامح شكري وزير الخارجيه المصري يقول بان
هذا للتنسيق اذا كان هذا للن تنسيق
المواقف فالازم بدات اصلا من البحرين
عندما او عندما كانت هي اول دوله تقاطع
دوله قطر وتضامنا معها دخلت السعوديه ومن
ثم دخلت الامارات ومن ثم دخلت مصر اذا كان
هذا للتنسيق فاين اليمن واين موريتانيا
واين المالديف هي دول ايضا مقاطعه ودول
اتخذت موقف بناء على مواقف الدول التي
قبلها ف بما ان العزمه لم تبدا جماعيه
بدات مفردا مفردا عن طريق البحرين ف كان
من الاجدر ان يكون ايضا معكم المالديف
واليمن وموريتانيا هذا هذه نقطه فيما
يتعلق ب النزول الذي اراه من البرج العاجي
عندما صدر البيان لم يركز او يؤكد على
قائمه المطالب ال 13 لم يقول ونحن نؤكد
على هذه المطالب بل قال ان هذه الست مبادئ
التي هي وانا اقول هذا الانتقال الى الوضع
العام الوضع الدولي وليس الوضع الخاص
الشخصنه الامور فيما يتعلق بالتجنيس وما
يتعلق باغلاق قناه الجزيره وبعض هذه
الامور فوضح بدانا نتكلم عن مبادئ عامه
هنا يعتبر هذا نوع من الالتفاف الدبلوماسي
لحفظ ماء الوجه والخروج من هذا المازق
اتحول السيد اسامه المناور الكويت التي هي
وسيط والتي تصل بها كان لافتا ذلك الاتصال
من وزير الخارجيه الامريكي ريك تيلرسون
بامير دوله الكويت نود ان نعرف الان
باعتقادك هل لازالت الازمه والملف برمته
بيد الخارجيه الامريكيه ام انه بات مقسما
الان وبات هناك انخراط اكثر من قبل البيت
الابيض بهذا الاتصال من قبل بل الرئيس
الامريكي وماذا عن الكويت باعتقادك عندما
يتحدث الجميع عن ضروره الوحده الخليجيه
ويتم الاتصال بامير الكويت هل يراد بالفعل
اعاده الملف ان صح التعبير الى
الكويت بسم الله والحمد لله والصلاه
والسلام على رسول الله داعيني فقط في
البدايه اتكلم عن
احباطي كمواطن خليجي كمواطن مسلم كمواطن
عربي من الوضع الذي وصلنا اليه الغريب ان
هذه الازمه بدات في افضل حالات دول مجلس
التعاون كان في هناك انسجام كان في توافق
تام بين دول يعني الدول جميعها تقريبا
كانت مشاركه في الدفاع عن المملكه العربيه
السعوديه في الحد الجنوبي كان هناك يعني
بدانا نشعر ان حلم الكونفدراليه الخليجيه
كان فعلا وشيكا ففه سبحان الله انهار كل
شيء بدون مقدمات وبدون
مبررات لو رجعنا الى قائمه المطالب او حتى
في الكلام
عن مشكله قطر يتكلمون بالعموم عن مشاكل
كانت من عقدين او من اكثر يعني تناسوا ان
قبل الازمه بايام كان هناك توافق يعني
الجميع سعد فيه الى ان وصلنا الى خيبه امل
جديده في المؤتمر الصحفي لليوم كنا نتمنى
ان مبادره سمو الامير صباح الاحمد شيخ
صباح الاحمد
و يعني سعي المجموعه بالوزراء الكويتيين
خلال الفتره شرقا وغربا محاوله لتوفيق
الاراء محاوله لراب هذا الصدع كنا نامل ان
نخرج بامر يعني مختلف نخرج بامر مختلف
عفوا سيد اسا بكل عام نخرج بشيء مختلف
تقول لكن هناك ايضا من كان يتوقع ان يكون
ذلك في البيت الخليجي هي ازمه خليجيه
اطرافها خليجيين دعك من من انضم اليهم
لاحقا يعني لماذا يعقد هذا الاجتماع اصلا
خارج الخليج لماذا لم يكن في الكويت مثلا
وهي الوسيط الذي قبل به الجميع محليا
اقليميا وحتى
دوليا هي الازمه صحيح خليجيه لكن احنا لا
نستطيع ان نتجاهل ان مصر انضمت لها انضمت
الى الدول المقاطعه ومصر اصبحت
طرف ثم ان مساله اختيار انعقاد هذا
المؤتمر اصحاب الشان هم اللي يحددونه يعني
هم هم اللي معنيين وهم الليي حددوه لكن
على كل حال اللي اليوم يعني انا بصراحه
كان عندي امل مثل ما قلت كمواطن خليجي ان
اليوم يكون في نهايه لمثل هذه المقاطعه
وهذا الحصار لو رجعنا الى تصريح محمد بن
عبد الرحمن وزير خارجيه قطر اللي اعلن عن
رفض هذه المطالب ولكن ترك يعني مثل
الابواب مفتوحه وقال نحن مستعدون ان
نتناقش على جميع هذه البنود ان يكون في
مفاوضات حقيقيه بين الطرفين المعنيين اللي
سمعناه اليوم اكثر كلمه ترددت موضوع
الارهاب وكذلك موضوع الدور التخريبي دون
دون تقديم دون تقديم ادله يعني هذه هذا من
طرف الدول المحاصره عفوا سيد اسامه مره
اخرى هذا من قبل الدول المحاصره لكن سمعنا
ايضا جمله لافته استوقفت الجميع ولعلها
هناك من بدا يحلل بانها ما قلبت اصلا هذا
البيان الذي لم يكن يفترض ربما ان يخرج
بهذه الطريقه لا نعلم هي مجرد تكهنات
وقراءات جمله الرئيس الامريكي دونالد
ترامب الذي تحدث عن حوار بناء يعني ما
الذي يعنيه ذلك باعتقادك هل سيضطر تضطر
مختلف الاطراف في نهايه الامر الى القبول
بهذا الحوار الذي بات لغه عالميه نسمعها
في اكثر من
عاصمه كل الدول تطالب
بالحوار يعني صراحه انا اعتقد ان دونالد
ترامب الرئيس الامريكي هو اللي يعني
المتابع لتغريدات يعلم انه قد يكون هو سبب
رئيس في مثل هذه الاز
هو كان يتكلم عن ان انجازاتنا تحققت ومن
ضمنها ما يحدث اليوم في الشرق الاوسط ما
اعتقد ان طرف نزيه يعني ما
اعتقد الوضع الحالي او المؤشرات تعطي ان
دونالد ترامب يسعى جاهدا او يسعى حقيقه
الى ان يلم شمل الدول الخليجيه او الدول
العربيه اطراف الازمه فهذا الكلام اعتقد
انك استهلاك سياسي لا اكثر ولا اقل اما
اما اليوم مثل ما ارجع على الموضوع نفسه
اللي كان موضوع الارهاب لو ثبت على اي
دوله انها فعلا تمول الارهاب الوضع اختلف
عالميا العالم بشكل عام في شرقه وغربه
عانى من الارهاب ومن تبعاته بل ان بعض
الدول الداعمه للارهاب تكون
عرضه لن تكون تحت البند السابع او وفق
الفصل السابع لميثاق الامم المتحده وهذا
له تبعات خطيره لكن يبدو ان ما في احد قدم
اي ادله حقيقيه او حتى قراء لها مسوغات
تفيد ان قطر داعمه لمثل هذا الموقف ا طبعا
تبقى معي تبقى معي اتحول مره اخرى لضيفنا
الكريم هنا السيد احمد سيطي اشار ضيفنا
السييد اسامه المناور من الكويت الى ان ما
يقوم به او يغرد به او حتى الاتصال
الهاتفي هو مجرد طبعا نتحدث عن الرئيس
الامريكي ومجرد استهلاك سياسي لا يعتد به
هل باعتقادك ان امريكا تملك رفاهيه بالفعل
ان
تلعب ان صح التعبير او ان تكون مواقفها
مختلفه بهذه الطريقه كان لافت كان ايضا
تصريح لمسؤول امريكي رفيع اصر على ضروره
الوحده الخليجيه كمصلح امريكيه اشارت
اطراف عديده هل من مصلحه امريكا ان تعيش
هذه المنطقه ايه حاله من ربما الزعزعه
وعدم الاستقرار ما في شك ان هذا امر يعني
يصب في صالح السياسه الامريكيه اي
اضطرابات موجوده في في اي منطقه امريكا
لها نفوذ فيها من صالحها ان يكون الوضع
بما هو عليه كما هو هل تفطن ترامب باعتقاد
الى ذلك ولو متاخرا ام يعني نحن نود ان
نفهم موقفه هذا هل يمكن بالفعل ان يعتد
ويبنى عليه ام انه كتغير دت ومواقف سابقه
لا تنفك ان تتغير لا هو يمكن ان يشتري
مواقف سياسيه ومواقف ايضا اقتصاديه من هذه
الازمات كما هو الحال عندما اتى الى
الرياض لياخذ مئات المليارات من الدولارات
ويسمح لهذه المجموعه باتخاذ اجراءاتها هو
سمح لهامش من الوقت ان لم يكن هذا الوقت
كافي لقيام بالهدف الذي كان موضوع لهذه
الازمه فلربما فيما بعد ان يعود ويقول
اعطيتكم الوقت الكافي الان يجب ان نعود
الى الصواب لم تنجزوا
مهمتكم على اكمل وجه طبعا رده الفعل
الدوليه هي التي اوقفت ترامب وهذه
المجموعه عند حدها عندما يتكلم ترامب عن
حوار بناء هذا هو ما غير المسار لان هذه
كما يقولون كلمه السر لهذه المجموعه التي
كانت في في القاهره ايضا عندما هم تكلموا
عن على سبيل المثال البند الثالث في في
الذي يتكلم عن الالتزام باتفاقيه الرياض
والاتفاقيه في 2013 والاتفاقيه المكمله
لها وحتى عطفا على السؤال للاخ اسامه في
الكويت سام المناور ان لماذا لم تكن هي في
الكويت على سبيل المثال هذه هذا الاجتماع
فانا اقول انه ايضا من
الخطا حتى القانوني ان يتكلم وزير خارجيه
مصر عن اتفاقيه تخص دول مجلس التعاون
الخليجي وان تكون هذه هذا البند بالتحديد
ان يكون في هذه في هذا البيان بعد هذا
الاجتماع فما دخل مصر في اتفاقيه الرياض
التي التي هي شان خليجي بحت ضيف يقول
بانها مع المقاطعين هو مثل ما قلت انا هي
بدات بالبحرين ثم السعوديه هو ترتيب مشى
بهذا المجال للوصول الى اهداف معينه انا
اقول ان لانها كانت اهداف شخصيه هناك من
يرغب بالمال هناك من يرغب بزوال قطر هناك
من يرغب
ايضا بوصول الى
الى مناصب سياسيه معينه كل هذه اجتمعت في
في تلك المطالب هناك من يريد ان يكتم صوت
حر ف هذذه مطالب شخصيه اجتمعت في القائمه
المطالب في في الطلبات التي قدمت عندما
جاء ترامب وقال لهم اذهبوا الى الحوار
البناء هذا من اتصال من الطائره عرفوا ان
المهله انتهت ويجب ان نتكلم الان وفق
القانون الدولي وهذا ايضا م صرح في وزير
خارجيه الامارات عبد الله بن زايد عندما
قال بان المطالب ستكون وفق القانون الدولي
والسؤال الذي يطرح او المباد التي يتكلمون
عنها والسؤال الذ يطرح نفسه هل كانت مطالب
لا تتماشى مع القانون الدولي حتى تكون
مطالبكم الحاليه وفق القانون الدولي ايضا
هناك من الملفت للنظر انه يوجد انقسام بعد
ترامب يوجد انقسام في في المشهد ما بين
الاربع دول اذا اتسع الوقت سنتكلم عنه
فيما بعد للاسف لم يبقى معنا كثير من
الوقت اتحول بسؤال اخير لسيد اسامه
المناور الجميع يعني يؤكد على الدور
الكويتي الجميع يؤكد على ضروره ايجاد هذا
الحل في البيت الخليجي هل نشهد باعتقادك
في الفتره المقبله مع زيارات او دخول
الامم المتحده على الخط التاكيد الامريكي
ايضا اضافه للمواقف السابقه هل سنشهد ربما
اطلاق
مفاوضات من الكويت او ترعاها
الكويت طبعا احنا اتمنى لان الخروج عن
دائره البيت الخليجي له تبعاته يعني مثل
ما عرفنا الموقف الامريكي والمعبر الواضح
عن موقف الاداره الامريكيه هو ما صرحت به
الممثله ممثله امريكا او السفيره
الامريكيه في الامم المتحده التي قالت نصا
احنا لابد من ان نضغط على الطرفين حتى
نحقق اكبر فائده اذا هم خصوم هم ليسوا
يعني بذلك الحرص كما نتوقع على راب الصدعه
او على لم شمل البيت الخليجي لو عدنا مره
اخرى الى ما قاله الشيخ صباح الاحمد بان
يعني نحن جيل بنى مجلس التعاون الخليجي
ويعز علينا او ان نرفض او سنقاتل دون ان
ينهار هذا المجلس فاعتقد ان هذه راح تكون
حجر الزاويه اليوم بالفعل الخليجيون هم هم
المعنيون بالمقام الاول للوحده مثل ما قلت
لك اختي احنا في السابق او قبل حتى هذه
الازمه بايام كنا نعتقد ان مساله
الكونفدراليه الخليجيه الوحده الخليجيه
الكامله يعني قاب قوسين او ادنى فجاه كل
شيء انهار لو رجعنا مره اخرى وتجرد وتنازل
كل من الطرفين وقدم التنازلات حرصا لبقاء
هذا الكيان هذا الكيان تقريبا هو الكيان
العربي الوحيد الذي بقى صامدا نر للاسنا
فرصه اخرى للحديث حول هذه النقطه ونقاط
اخرى معك اشكرك جزيل الشكر لان وقتنا
انتهى تماما اسامه المناور عضو مجلس الامه
الكويتي السابق كنت معنا من الكويت كما
نشكر جزيل الشكر السيد احمد سليطي الصحفي
والاعلامي القطري l